have you had a chance to talk to
anderson cooper
kathy griffin has ended her friendship
with anderson cooper
back in may a viral photo of kathy
holding a donald trump mask covered in
fake blood
drastically altered griffin's life the
controversy caused the comedian
endorsement deals and several gigs
including cnn's new year's eve broadcast
she's co-hosted with anderson cooper for
the past
decade we're still friends and uh look i
mean i've
said a lot you know i said what i said
about i i didn't think what she said was
appropriate um but
i wish her the best and i i think you
know i hope she bounces back and
she's gonna be touring in like a minute
don't you think i mean
incredibly funny and and a lot of people
love her and and i think she'll be
you know she'll be bounced back from
this despite claiming the two were still
friends during a july 26 appearance on
watch what happens live
cnn confirmed to the cut that cooper
didn't even contact griffin until august
10th
two weeks after watch what happens live
according to the article cooper publicly
stating that they were still friends
without personally checking on her
hurt griffin when he finally reached out
griffin let him know that their
friendship was over